again thank you everyone for being
present with me for this ultimate nature
of our reality and talk and I would love
to open the q8 whoever would like to
start a song and it would mean being
treated like a discussion too so not
just Q&A for me but a discussion
and make sure you talk directly yeah
like I say yeah yeah I didn't put
everyone just make sure you do that
that's not one yeah you know a lot of
times I do I'd like to hear others talk
and that helps me kind of gear into what
I'm thinking more but I don't mind
jumping up first here too
i I really I mean I really like what
your what your present your presenting I
think as a post-christian atheist I I
mean this this stuff to me is I mean I I
I'm asked many times about well you know
you give up Christianity so then what do
you have to live for you don't believe
there's a god and I I know that God God
is not a sentient being and so I know
that that's the first question most
people have when there are non atheists
is theist as well you know how do you
you know what do you live for and to me
when you start looking at what you're
talking about here to me this is where
humans can expand way beyond what we've
been we've been held back and and in
religion plays a significant role in
human evolution I I don't deny that and
in it and it still plays a role in
current society I think it's I mean
these are to work for an organization
that does great great work and I I
attended a funeral last week and a
baptism and in a Chris Boldt in a
Christian Church and so one is a
evangelical church
the the more upbeat music and engaging
younger generation and the the baptism
was the Catholic Church so it's really
profound to see the differences in their
presentations however both of these
things bring people together and and
people want to come together and now do
i I think that most people in those
facilities believe every word that said
no do most people that go to a church
believe deeply in what said or deeply in
what's in the Bible no I don't believe
most of them do most of them I believe
the majority of them go for that peace
that community peace they've they've
developed a strong strong community and
strong connection with other people and
I tend to be somebody that that I think
deeper about these things and so I love
this kind of thing this talk and I and I
love that the expansion that it's given
me in my life and the in in in in
thinking like this and and then seeing
the limitations that were put upon me by
my society which which every society is
going to do is going to put limitations
upon us and it is up to us and it's it's
been up to the great spiritual leaders
of our time that have gone beyond those
types of limitations so I think it's
it's it is the next expansion into you
know the great what human beings the the
potential of human beings is as
phenomenal and I think you touch on this
you know just even from the very
beginning of I teach yoga and
I do meditation and and and just
starting out at the beginning in a
visualization of Here I am and here's
how expansive I can be and then coming
back to how how micro small I can be and
those are the things I I focus on in
meditation - I think it's you know it's
because it's so incredible - to see the
the power of what life is and the life
in me is no different than a blade of
grass and I just happen to be I think
you know I do believe other than
something that's probably out in another
planet somewhere that we don't know of
there is nothing sentient at the level
that we are as human beings you know I
don't want to say on the in the universe
because I do believe there possibly
could be something but but we are this
we have achieved the highest level of
sentient beings and other than what we
don't know of in the rest of the
universe and there is no sentient being
out there pulling any strings or there's
no sentient universe that has a
direction of where this universe is it's
only it goes to that simplicity I like
that snake demonstration - because it
goes to that simple of a thing is that
life wants to continue on and life is
going to continue on regardless of
whether we survive or not in which we
are not going to survive you see I am
NOT
going to survive my consciousness isn't
so eventually that will be gone and yet
this life that's in me that's the same
as a blade of grass that will continue
in some way it has to thank you
you are
your name Alan Alan yeah Alan I am Terry
yep
before we started the talk I shared with
my friends I said I'm not quite sure if
I'm floored or grounded it seems as if
it's one in the same and but the
flooring feels like a shock like a blown
away like to a new level of
understanding filling floored though the
grounding is still being here and now
and with you and us and all of it
I find myself I recognize that I've been
born again repeatedly or several times I
think about the Who I am today
hurtling life I've recently branded
myself as the hurdle life coach 34
I think about being born as Terry the
infant and then as my experiences
through life or those deck of cards give
me more and more identity or substance
to that identity I recall associations
and milestones and benchmarks graduating
high school graduating college achieving
levels of success in society and and
thinking about those identities in which
are those labels in which were placed
upon me and how I aligned with them I
also recall just spiritual awakenings
though beyond my name you know beyond my
brand beyond even my gender
and walking through my faith and to my
understanding of God and divine in life
baptisms that that outward expression of
the death and resurrection experience in
that in my life for different times
being baptized and truly believing in
each one of those experiences that was a
new birth and a rebirth in this
interaction so it seems it feels as if
I'm being born yet again like there is a
new level of consciousness and awareness
and awakening' set has come through your
presentation to me I'm grateful for this
time for this space for this circle it's
oddly familiar that we are strangers yet
one in the same so it seems and so thank
you
you know for being a light and for
sharing your understanding as you have
seeked it out and you know put it
together and give it away
I find myself learning new things today
I heard briefly of your abilities to ask
great questions and throughout your
presentation were very very
life-changing thought-provoking
questions
several questions
and it seems so it feels as if those
questions were like the anchors or like
that those were the takeaways you may
get poopy pulled away and some of the
other information but those questions
were so weave so well and really caught
my attention to really want to spend
time in that place you know pondering
those thoughts I truly appreciate your
conviction to what you're certain of
what's important our relationship with
God the divine the source and I
appreciate your your your universal
approach to honoring you know people's
way to the source you know though I
aligned personally as a Christian as a
believer choosing to have faith in the
story of Jesus Christ and his ability to
be both man and human I mean divine and
human I recognize at least in my walk
that that God or creator
is bigger than my religion
and I embrace other people's and walk
and way I accept that this creator that
created my Lord my God also created this
really really big universe I mean really
really really big universe and to love
life or to accept life or the see life
as an interconnected web of oneness to
the blade of grass to the star in the
sky to the universes beyond you know
that in which has not even been
discovered that in which we know tells
us that this place this thing is so much
bigger than me it's just
and so I share in the appreciation of
the opening exercise that we went out
and away and then back and inside and
then to claim a oneness with all of it
to truly really have power and authority
and
it's like a Dominion over how far we can
go or take it
I enjoyed the conversations around
portals I love that that that piece were
the you highlighted the artists in which
he created something on earth that truly
you know merged you know the the divine
and the practical and the spiritual and
the theoretical and and so it seemed
that there was a teleportation from
visioning from from observing that piece
of art I think the words were you said
artists can create portals I found it
difficult to use my logical mind while
listening to you present you know the
desire to take notes as a lifelong
learner and want to capture that in
which is being spoken but also being
drawn so much to you subconsciously and
in spirit you know feeling called to
just absorb that in which you were
sharing versus trying to capture or trap
it with pen and pad and ink and so there
was a complete failure and thorough
note-taking but of complete confidence
in the connection that was made and the
awareness that was raised in me through
you and so for that I am grateful and
for you and for this presentation and
and the eye-opening experience that I've
had here this evening here at seal so
thank you
so much yeah
brother
we appreciate you thank you for sharing
this experience with us tonight
I too appreciated your grounding
the facilitation of grounding at the
beginning of your share it's very
helpful I think there was there were
only a couple of seconds where my
attention diverted from what you were
imparting and I was able to very quickly
return to the groundedness because of
your preparation so thank you for that I
think that you successfully accomplished
giving us something in a very simple
form that lends itself to great
complexity
so you would you really modeled what you
what you preached what you taught us
I might not be close enough with a mica
pop apologies looks like you're good
am I good yeah can I talk a little
louder if you buy yeah
I love the the clarity that you offered
about the absolute necessity of an
awareness of ultimate reality and namely
the importance of connection with source
with our divine
I think it was really helpful what you
shared about the deck of cards that our
life is and that every second is a card
and the importance of applying love to
all of those loving them all past
present and future regardless of the
trauma they're in and that we are we are
a river we are meant to be a river in
the midst of it loving at all it's very
powerful
so you indicated that this could be also
a QA experience so I would like to ask
if you would be willing to speak more to
[Music]
what you touched upon about the gifts
the unique gifts that people discover in
their life experience you mentioned that
it is one of the paramount aspects of
our life in this world is to know
thyself and to discover and express the
unique gifts that each individual has so
I would really like to hear you speak
more to that
I have such deep gratitude
and humility and love for you all thank
you
it's transforming for me to hear how you
feel afterward
it's a great question
in a way
takes us to the symphony that's being
played and we're the painting and the
ways to see what our gift is within that
Symphony or the painting is that
whatever that gift is it's our gift that
we get to bring to ourselves to our
families to our communities in the world
and it's not for us to take our gift and
start saying that someone else's gift
looks like this and immediately that
comparative feeling takes away from the
beauty of what the gift is and so for
some the gift is being a good friend or
a good family member and that's it to
the gift that's it and that's a
beautiful note in the symphony a
beautiful melody a beautiful paint
stroke and it's the different color
let's call that color orange
so being a good friend or good family
members and color orange and then you
can Chuck's to pose that with
with solving something as complex as one
of the sustainable development goals or
the theory of everything and so maybe
that is a blue paint stroke on the
canvas or a different melody in the work
astre and the symphony and so in a sense
one shooting big aiming big is
incredible and it's great to inspire
children to know that they can aim big
yet it's also cool to say that hey this
color orange where you're a friend are a
good family member that's an important
contribution to the painting as well as
this big blue paint stroke that solves a
grand challenge for our society
you ready yeah yeah
Jacob Alan Oh Terry yeah so they started
with the question again that you are
yeah you are out a light there I am
Terry
you spoke to the warning of not to be
distracted by the culture war I
appreciated that I appreciated that
short brief quick but clear warning not
to be distracted by the culture war I'm
curious to hear you expound deeper upon
that just as I you know in myself work
to love thyself know thyself but also
they'll serve others and love people and
solve problems and fix things I
definitely know myself to be called to
the world call to society in my work and
my duty and my sacrifices so I'm curious
to hear more about the risk there in
being in those distractions are
particularly what are those distractions
and what they look like or what are you
referring to
another great question
there's this
gorgeous calling for us upon birth to
wreak immune back with source with this
divine and there are so many
distractions that would get in the way
of us kind of like tripping over things
and like forgetting that that's actually
really important to do and everyone has
their own journey of remembering that we
come from source and that but that needs
to be a first principle and everyone has
their own different ways of doing that
process one one of the ways and we were
talking a bit about your mentor before
we started one of your mentors this idea
that someone can come in and maybe see
one of those like obstacles that someone
may be tripping over and I can give an
example of maybe one of those obstacles
is like I mean
when we wake up in the morning and when
we go to bed at night connect to that
divine drop into your body and drop into
how beautiful it is that you are alive
along with so many other people on their
journeys and that when you tap into like
what your journey is every one of those
debts of the cards in the deck and being
in love with the cards in the past and
in love with the fate of you at the
direction of the future that it makes it
so that I mean the alternative is that
what do we do we're literally scrolling
through a newsfeed when we wake up in
the morning and go to bed at night
that's the alternative so juxtapose
those two things which one is going to
make you more of a Divine Being
it's clear it's a very clear answer and
it and we attend to that practice when
we water our own seed in our garden
it'll have fruits for us when we don't
water that seed with our spiritual
practice in the morning at night if we
surrender our essence over to algorithms
and news feeds tribalism echo chambers
the culture wars cognitive ease you
can't communicate a multivariate nuanced
position in a tiny little post it's
really hard to do that it's much easier
to do it in person and to know that it's
gonna take longer for me to establish
these 10 variables that some are Pro
somewhere khansamar 5 different other
sub points but that is not just a simple
binary cognitive East answer to
something so just opposing those two
things like the culture wars and the the
news feeds and the algorithms and doing
that in the morning and when we go to
bed at night versus connecting to the
divine in those pristine moments
it's even more important when you have a
family because if you're rolling over
and you have a partner that's laying in
the bed with you and you're rolling over
and grabbing your phone you are missing
out on a critical opportunity to adorn
them in the morning and when you go to
bed at night
[Music]
and this is and this is a partner that
you may be starting a family with or
have started a family with it may also
be someone that's just close to you that
that you may be in the same residence
with I'm staying here with my mother in
Sioux Falls and we make it at least a
minimum a amount of adoring each other
in the morning and in the evening and
that's critical again that's a mother a
father a brother a sister your roommate
just being appreciative at least and
grateful that they are there cohabiting
the same space mentioning a moment of
thank you so much for teaching me about
this thing that we experienced together
a couple days ago thank you for sharing
life with me thank you for that meal
that you cooked for us there's just so
many different ways of treating those
moments in the morning and the evening
like they are just divine precious gifts
rather than surrendering them over to
culture wars
thank you thank you
because there's two things number I
guess maybe the one the first first item
that I have it engraved on an iPad of
mine and it's a quote by Rumi and I just
I haven't thought of it in a while and
he says close your eyes fall in love
stay there that quote is just it's so
simple and then and then the second
thing is your lat
I I saw a video of Babaji I don't know
if you've ever heard of him he and and I
think I have the right name and I think
if you'd look online he was a yogi and I
mean we hear about these Yogi's and I
had one of these Yogi's that that is one
of these people that abused his power
and I think maybe even continues to
abuse his his status
but this man there's there's lots of
video these these people from the US
went over there
it was during the time and and I kind of
think I tracked it down through
there's the song I always think of the
song by the Beatles Timothy Timothy
Leary and and then Ram Dass mm to
practice with hallucinogenics out it and
Yale and Timothy Leary continued his his
hallucinogenic approach and around Oz
went to went to India and
he was he he was had no intention to go
there for the purpose of learning
anything about himself or anything and
somehow he got railroaded into going to
see this this guy and and and he said he
just could not he could not leave and
and he even had L and he he talked about
he had a handful of LSD and he gave it
to this guy and the guy just gulped it
down and it had no effect on this guy
this guru and and he is actually a
different person but this Babaji was
really somehow associated with him and
so these people had gone even before and
and videotape this Babaji gaya and
there's this one video and III think
it's one of the most profound things
I've ever seen
there's everything about this guy when
you watch him it's this it is when
people you read about presents one of my
favorite books is Eckhart Tolle's book
the power of now and you read about it
but but you don't you you you know you I
read I read that book seven times in
well I was teaching yoga and Europe and
and I just was like there's something
here but in somebody somebody actually
suggested to to me we had yoga teachers
that would would teach it would come to
your class and they would give you
feedback afterwards and and and I asked
her for feedback and she said I have one
suggestion the power of not read that
book and and I never talked to her about
it again I do but I kept reading this
book and read this book and like what is
it that she wants me to kid but there's
something in there
and and then I went to Augusta Georgia
and I had this mentor who I think he he
had this sense of presence and and then
it then it it hit me and there there is
there is nothing that can replace one on
one when you're with someone there's
nothing and this Babaji guy and in one
of these videos I watched a woman comes
up to ask him some real you know deep
philosophical question I can't think of
it now and and and a lot of them they
would sit down and they would touch the
feet of the guru and and and and things
and yeah as she asked the question in
and and sometimes he would get into
little things with people were there
would be you could see this this mental
battle going on and but in this case I
don't know what it went what I can't
recall what happened to her I wish I
could pull it up now it's it's real
short but but they both just started
laughing and he and he wouldn't laugh
often this and I don't know if you've
heard of Mooji is another person a lot
of people this too and I like what he a
lot about him he studied under this
bhava cheap but this guy would always at
some point be laughing and and in that
but I think that's that's something with
a guru if you're if your guru isn't
laughing and you're not having fun and
it's all serious I think it's a good
time to hit and hit it and run because
that's how my the this guy that I he I
was just there to learn yoga I was not
there to learn any spiritual stuff who
is Vikram Chaudhary is the guy's name
and
I went there and everybody went there to
learn a physical fitness yoga which is
what America is experiencing now and I
I'm fine with that I'm actually even
looking at possibly opening a yoga
studio that is fitness driven and I
think it's okay
however if I were to then profess myself
as this guru to these people then then
that's a whole other deal and so I I
just I like that that gives me a very
solid sense of where you are and your
presence and your understanding and that
you see it it's light-hearted to it is
it's it's it's you know we're not here
cracking atoms but kind of we are
laughter helps yeah I don't know that
there's a question there's a thanks
also just what what you said full
circles in the sense that there's so
much of this new wage spiritual
awakening at times that there can be
deception there too and it's important
to be very careful because you know yoga
means union with the divine and with our
and you mentioned the first quote it's a
fun full circle to the very first thing
that you said which was that when you
close your eyes and you fall in love
with that with you yourself that then
you don't need a guru and that whole
idea of like I am NOT your guru is so
damn true and anyone that says that they
are or that they rely on one is is not
closing their eyes and loving themselves
and yeah yeah that I just wanted to also
say that in addition we said thank you
I think I love you expression love
yourself because that is really deep
really deep if you start thinking about
this if you close your eyes and start
breathing deep inside think about
yourself go from small things as
moleculus to so far as universe in come
back let's teach us a lot
teach us to fini infinitive extensions
of our self and at the same time
teaching us to be present in thank you
for this
thank you
passive there passive that way I'm
wearing the lavalier mic I would like to
ask a question there has been a way of
viewing and experiencing and feeling the
divinity and source and God
in a way that is respectful to all
journeys and so that word and it's as
soon as you start trying to put source
or God or the divine creation into words
and to our symbols that then it's and it
doesn't no longer becomes that eternal
God our source of creation yet the one
that I found so far that I think is
really good that I feel like let's start
with the word the word is pantheism
meaning all is God and when I was
discussing that with some of my friends
that have been studying the various
religions they actually said that the
idea of all being God is actually
present in a lot of the religions
I think belief confirmed its in Hinduism
it's in Buddhism it's in Islam it's in
Judaism I believe it's in Christianity
and I mean I'm just like if there is
some sort of a single word that we could
like pantheism like all is God maybe
there's a way to just galvanize people
together around something like that
- then elicit more friendships and
cooperations around the world about what
is the ultimate nature of our reality is
it like an all is God and then we can be
cool let's all like work on our progress
of communing with that in our own unique
ways let's all explore our gifts and
help people with the
uplifting their basic needs so that they
can explore what those gifts are and so
yeah so I'm curious what do you think
about that pantheism that all is God
[Music]
it's new
for me to hear it
conceptualized in a way where it then
becomes something besides God alone
creation itself the source though I feel
like its concept is one that is
universal and all-inclusive I still have
a slight sense of reservation to even
begin to find a way to conceptualize it
as you say the moment you begin to try
to put it into a word or religion or an
understanding it begins to take away
from that in which a very it is
and that is that about religion that I
think I've seen that divides us is says
that if it's not my religion therefore
your consequence for not believing as I
believe is this place of damnation hell
turmoil left behind it's the part of
religion I reject
I believe that God is love
and I was just speaking to this just
yesterday in a presentation I was giving
about accepting other people as they
reintegrate back into community and love
being a call to us as neighbors as
humans as as workers to love those in
which our reintegrating and in love
I mean to accept and I think in religion
where we begin to say well if you don't
believe this way then you won't be
accepted and that's where I struggle to
take a position to leave anyone behind
or to count anyone out I'm in the God
that I understand in the connection that
I have
I have
a question in that space and in that
rail I believe we'll have time to come
back to it let's come back to it after
yeah so I'll just honor all thoughts on
pantheism vias and pantheism can you
table the question you might remember it
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll walk back
there all right
bell tolling panties
Allen yes Laura
that's a really interesting question
and a worthy challenge
and in my experience and my belief truth
is truth
and when I hear someone speak truth I
identify it as such regardless of what
religion they might label themselves as
or what word they would use to describe
the divine to describe God so I feel
like part of something what you're
getting at can it be accomplished that
there's more of a sense of unity mm-hmm
for me that is accomplished when names
and labels are omitted mmm and when the
truth itself is spoken and lived out it
is recognizable because the truth is
evident to all regardless of where they
come from or how they were raised and
what they were exposed to anyone who
seeks the truth can find it it is
evident in all of creation mm-hmm
so truth such as we are all made in the
image of God what book does that come
from what faith does it come from it
doesn't matter because the truth itself
resonates with the Spirit that hears it
so I think in omitting the labels and
the names we may accomplish the goal
that you pose hmm if if people can can
think about I'm looking beyond that
label but I value the truth
yeah
and one unifying term that I kind of
feel in my heart right now is seeker mmm
I'm a seeker of truth that was just used
recently as well for me and I was like
wow okay because you're mentioning you
now which is interesting in a
testimonial after an interview they used
that word so please continue with your
relationship with that word
to be a seeker is not connected I think
with any certain faith it might resonate
more with one than another but if you're
seeking you're seeking truth and you
shall find it and that is the
graciousness of the divine the divine
being he will not he she the divine will
not that love is generous enough to not
withhold itself from anyone who seeks
the heart that seeks will be answered
and truth will be revealed to that
person
it's also interesting because that's
Steve
the position
in
JK Rowling's Harry Potter series of the
in Quidditch where the seeker would be
the one that's constantly flying around
trying to find the little believe it's
the snitch who was it called yeah yeah
gold thing flying around so that was a
seeker that was on each team that was
doing that so maybe there's also there's
so much story that all points in the
same direction which is so interesting
yeah yeah it's ancient truth yeah
ancient ancient there's a dawn of time
yeah that's good I like that like that
I like this microphone reminds me of Bob
Barker I say baby and make sure you
spade and neuter your pets everyone
remember did anybody ever watch Bob
Barker what price is right here that's
long microphone like this yep what's
your bet $1 $1 $1 and if you're over but
if you're over I go 50 cents you know
the the word that I that I started using
is inner rhythm and that's the word I
use for people because I I agree that
labels and and though you know if people
do use words like God and divine then
III ask them do you believe God is
sentient
that's and oftentimes I find with people
that they don't they don't understand
that word sentient and so then I
explained to them God is God thinking or
not thinking and sometimes they have to
it they have to pause and they don't
know and and a lot of times I don't
think that the religion or we challenged
them to it does God thing is God
thinking or not thinking and I believe
that God is not thinking and so these I
think that I I need these were when
people use the labels then I want to
have is is the universe thinking is the
universe sentient is it not sentient to
me that's very important to know because
if you know that that's the that's what
I feel I've over I feel I have overcome
to not seeing that there is anything
sentient I am the we as we know it we're
as high a level of sentient being that
that exists and it doesn't mean
the the truth that I know is any more
than than a dog because I have dogs that
I times sit and meditate with dogs and I
am just profoundly moved at their inner
rhythm their inner rhythm and III and
and it goes back to what you were
talking about is you know try to listen
to your heart and and if and and and so
this I guess you know is a you don't
mind me taking up time here you know in
this time when I was being mentored and
and and finding this presence there was
there were very many dark days and and
you know they talked about Jesus having
you know all this time and seven years
or and and Buddha sitting under a tree
for I mean long periods and and so it
was very very dark and there was one day
and and I would sit in Journal and and
there was one day it was really dark and
I was very frustrated and and really
just with everything you know career my
marriage is probably not gonna continue
I don't know if I like it where I live I
don't know what I'm gonna do you know it
just it comes to that and and I think
that you know sadly that we all and
maybe it's just seekers this is kind of
what you're talking about but the colors
of paint maybe it is just seekers maybe
you know other people don't have to
experience this maybe not everybody has
to experience this but me as a seeker I
think I had to experience that darkness
and the words that came to me were the
words from Paul Simon of the first words
of that song saying
hello darkness my old friend I've come
to talk with you again yeah and I just
could not believe you know how could
this darkness be a friend and and you
know what just for some reason and I
hadn't listened to that song for a long
long time but I I just wrote that down
and I just I just really sat with that
for a long time that he must have had a
profound type of an experience that that
these words that darkness is a friend
and so that was when to me that that I
saw that all the pain I have to sit with
that pain
because once I get through and I face
that pain like you talk about every card
I have to love
and once I've sat with all that pain
there's this inner rhythm this friend
that's that's in it's in everyone and so
that's I guess that's any word I and I
came up with the inner rhythm I want to
also mention there was a
the question that you posed to people
about is God's sentient there's a
part of that Ouroboros theory is that
there's a simplicity evolved to
complexity that the complexity becomes
kind of like a big neural network that
becomes then sentient so I'm not sure if
that would be the answer that an
Ouroboros style of cyclical creation is
in itself then sentient as it continues
evolving towards complexity and
realizing itself and then making more
creation so
yeah I mean cuz my I mean my basic you
know I like a blade of grass I don't
think is can think beyond itself though
though a blade of grass can have a
million different varieties so why did
that evolve like that I mean there is
there almost seems like what maybe what
you're saying it makes me think more
about it that they're there almost
appears to be re a you know you know a
fish that can make itself look like some
other species that is not a fish or
something you know it is there seems to
be some sentient this sentient level but
but as far as I think of the word
sentient is that we we are able to we
are able to think beyond ourselves and
into you know I can I can think I can
see outside of myself we're an animal or
a plant or something I just don't I
don't believe that they can can be good
God could source them do that process
that you're talking about it's a good
question yeah seems like it's in
potentially a unlike I know I'm gonna
puttan I'm the punt omnipresent essence
well in yeah and that this gets back to
where i don't i don't like the word god
this so much because well then it
becomes when when a person uses the word
god it's a and i've read the other
things that have stated that that god in
in ancient times oftentimes did not
represent a he or she it represented
unlike energy all that is although is
god yeah still go back to that over and
over again ass until I find something
that can encompass it greater than that
those are if you must put words then it
seems as though pantheism pretty decent
and all-encompassing yeah also yes let's
a little more and then let's and let's
do that what you had tabled afterward so
just a reflection
[Music]
when you mentioned today that we have
become gods without wisdom is it
possible that other forms of life that
are not as sentient as we are are fuller
in wisdom than we with our sentience are
amen
and perhaps the divine or the source is
the infinite intelligence that is in all
of us amen
and what's the inner rhythm of those
animals and plants and insects and even
the the collective essence of the entire
planet as a Gaia as a spirit I mean it's
ridiculous
seems like it's ridiculous to feel like
the
the inner rhythm of all those things
that we listed feels like that is
constantly divinely connected to source
without any like hiccups in a sense it
just feels like it's a pristine pure
connection to source there was a funny
meme that I saw recently which was that
there were like you know birds chirping
and you know we when we like your birds
were like gorgeous right but like it was
funny because the birds went chirping
and they had little like cloud bubbles
of what they're saying and it was like
wake up humans you are enslaved and I
think that the birds were chirping and
the guy in the bottom frame was was like
such beautiful bird chirping noise
this is fun
also a reflection and then a thought and
the final question I hadn't been
challenged in that way to think of to be
axed rather or not you know it's God
thinking or not
I typically intentionally skirt
conversations around politics and
religions I intentionally strive to not
take a position but only that in which
is in love and that I accept you as you
are where you're at and believing where
you're going and to model that and I
hope to inspire others to live the same
but as I received the question of is God
thinking
my initial thought and responses aligns
with doors that that is and I were gonna
go there and say that he is not just in
my relationship with God
and mother earth but he is not thinking
however I recognize that in my thinking
that and in my connection with universe
and source that though God is not
thinking yet I am thinking for sure God
is still moving
and there seems to be for me that my
belief tells me that there is a purpose
for all things and for all of us and
that and in the way that I've packaged
it in my own walk I say that man's
choices doesn't change God's purpose and
so it's God thinking no God already has
the plan it's already written to come
back to me that is the thought that is
the plan that is the way that the seeker
would find me and no matter what I
choose to do or how I think or where I
land or where I was born or which
religion I identify with his thought his
plan is already written and it's for you
to come back to me and no matter the
choices you make it doesn't change the
purpose that's already written and
intended and so I think in that that XT
gives us the power retained that we are
godlike and we can create co-creating
and step into that that God likeness to
change things and shift things and
manifest things and so
I say God is moving through me through
you through us through it all through it
all I want to celebrate your
presentation to say that I love the
pictures I'm curious in in my own
journey as a broadcaster and the speaker
to like the word you found such majesty
and such inspiration and that in which
it's not urgent to share but just to say
that I appreciated the visual aids in
the journey the beautiful picture of the
being and the chakras and the connection
and the people and it was just it was
all there and to to see myself one in
the same as a spiritual being having a
human experience and in that for the
first time in my life truly I believe
Allen I was driving here celebrating my
mother
she turned 54 today hmm
and she is a woman of joy and laughter
and acceptance and she's celebrating 54
years today and I recall as a child
fearing to tremble
the thought of her passing on the day
she died and I've had a brother who has
left already and planned many friends
and close family members who have left
already I've experienced death I know
death in that way of a loved one
and as I've been journey and as of late
and as I've been connecting with others
like us to believe that death is only
the beginning a new beginning to believe
that it doesn't end mmm that life
continues after this into a space into a
dimension of all knowingness of
limitlessness and of joy of love of
laughter of warship and I felt myself
for the first time today so it seemed
that that I would celebrate
the day the last day if my mother was on
her last day that because of my newfound
belief and where she's going that I
could still be as happy for her today at
54 as I would be for her if she was at
the end and then that I would
wholeheartedly believe that I would see
her again and be with her again
you know when it became my time to then
pass over and so I'm curious in your
thoughts around this what does the end
look like life after death here with
your understanding of the source code
and Quantum's and all these things
beyond my own research and understanding
I'm curious into your beliefs on what
happens after this when the shell when
the heart stops
hmm let me have a story about your
mother happy birthday shout-out shot
Cynthia Liggins Cynthia Lee we love you
omaha nebraska shoutout
yeah well also the slides as well can
mention that on the ways that
miss them too
aim to make the visual aid as much of a
compression of that key point as
possible without words just a visual aid
and then yeah just using the words I did
write the don't get distracted by
culture wars on that slide because I was
like just really wanting a hammer that
one home but yeah I would that would
probably be and then just simple
searches on different
everything from the classic search
engine searches all the way to there's
tons of image galleries to use and yeah
really just trying to compress all of
the Keith's essence of that point like
that one where it was like how do you
bring your gifts forward or the
importance of bringing gifts forward and
it's just like this divine human that
looks like they're beautifully communing
and expressing themselves like that
would be like the one that I pick and so
I think I looked up for that one I think
I looked up Kundalini awakening hmm you
know because it's hard to find us an
image like that and see if to look up
specific words to find stuff like that
so that would be another recommendation
I like saying I don't know yeah and I
love saying I don't know nice
yeah because seem like if everything
else it's like so cyclical it's like
some spiritual leader has been learning
a lot from like indigenous elders and a
lot of them say that spirit meets with
body for school and an earth is school
and we come with our mission that we're
here to bring forth our gifts that were
here to bring forth and have school of
all the lessons that we have along that
way and that afterward we go back to
source and then potentially choose to
some say it's an older spirit one that's
incarnated a lot for your lessons of
school some say there's a younger spirit
you know it's an interesting way of
putting it yes sometimes it's
interesting thinking about like like
your own like ancestral like lineage and
you like look up the tree right like
like multi generations back and then
you can kind of like see like yourself
carrying features of the tree from the
previous ancestors and so yeah yeah and
so yeah that's kind of a also an
interesting potential some people say
that there isn't I like when you think
you don't know yeah because I agree if I
don't know I rather to say I don't know
then guess about something and give
wrong impression we exist in and coming
back in recognition that is something
what we don't know you don't know
because you did not experience this I
didn't experience this and probably
nobody experiences some people do say
that they have experienced it it's quite
interesting that's quite interesting but
that case about feeling how they feel
about says and this is where science and
spirituality kind of that's kind of
that's me but how you can say for sure
if you been already here if you walk
through different body you know and
experience this life things that is
really philosophical and really
technical too at the same time I agree
with the term probably I don't know
yeah that's it good way to put do you
guys have um thoughts on I guess I'd
have one one thought on I mean I I think
that it's it's it's so much more
important for you to live now hmm
when you when in in my in my view I know
there's I know there's nothing when I'm
done
there is absolutely nothing and I have
and and you know this goes back to you
know I've sat with the darkest in me and
so I I know that it can get no darker
than that and and so therefore when
there's nothing that there's nothing so
now I need to do as much as I can and
one one thought that came to me is you
know in but this is where religion has
worked well though and like in in you
look at the losing the the guy or in
over a next the China has pushed him out
the why can I think of the the the
Buddhist gentleman that has been booted
out of China Dalai Lama yeah and I mean
you look at that child when he you know
he was found and they said well there's
this is the next Dalai Lama and so this
child you know how this child was raised
and just imagine if we raised every
child like the Dalai Lama but they don't
they don't do that
I mean they they have they were not very
they were most of the people in in that
area we're not treated very well even
prior to the Chinese coming the Dalai
Lama now he got you know he he got
treated tremendously well and
and and and I think why you know if we
could take those types of examples and
use them I mean if every child was
raised like the Dalai Lama I mean wow
just imagine where we would be I mean he
is the most content and happy and
cheerful person that wanted one of the
most he's a person that laughs a lot too
I like him in that sense but also be
slightly careful because then all of the
paint strokes are like green then if all
the children if everybody is raised yeah
so it's like both interesting to unlock
their spiritual connection and gifts but
also yeah the same methodology but but I
guess I mean maybe not the exact same
methodology but the fact that he was he
was raised as as the next coming of God
basically is how you're raised when
you're the Dalai Lama and so what if we
raised every child that they I mean with
that spirit that you are versus you know
which which we're all very familiar with
the Catholic Church that says you know
you and you have sinned and the in the
older days I lived across the street
from children that went to the Catholic
Church and and you know they had to
dress a certain way their parents were
extremely strict on them they were
beaten oftentimes and I mean how did
they you know when you have a child a
child that's so beautiful and has so
much and there we have so much to learn
from them and yet they're sinners that
we've got to beat the sinner I mean
that's how it used to be I mean they're
not I don't think the Catholics are
quite that way anymore but that's how it
was when I was a child and I mean I just
think we're I think we're getting closer
and closer I think children you know
people talk about helicopter parents and
all this and in a sense that's a good
thing though I mean parents are involved
when I was a child
come home and here's a little bit go
outside and and I was raised by the
neighborhood I was raised by my older
brother and my older brother was not a
kind person he was kind of a jerk
extension what'd you say I think that's
really important to be present in this
life and be in full potential of you
over yourself realize all your potential
because you don't know what will be next
you don't know what will be it will be
something else besides this life things
like you say every day take every day as
your last day and Rihanna's full
potentials you can enjoy your life as
you present and like try to be happy too
I think that's really important I think
people losing happiness lately we don't
know anymore how to be happy how to
accept life and be happy be happy for
ourself be happy for all our family be
happy for all the kids treat your kids
with happiness and try to grow they grow
them up as happiest person too because
kids right now is kind of being
themselves more with electronic with
technology and everything else I think
we're losing touch we're losing to be in
contact with our own kids with this ex
potential you know technology I think we
needed two more we connected we
connected with family be connected with
source be connected that's really
important
some of the spiritual leaders that we've
interviewed in that I've frequently
visit their teachings
they speak to the exponential technology
transition as a grand challenge that
society has to figure out how to handle
because there's this beautiful
biological capacity for us to be a
channel and anchor the divine in us
biologically and it happened so much by
just having the things that we've been
mentioning in this conversation working
on on those things yet we've
externalized so much two of our time and
essence to technology and that the
acid-like appendages of our being that
you can you can actually like you can
physically sense your own stress levels
when you're behind a keyboard versus
talking to someone in person and
and you're much less likely to do any
sort of harm to someone else in person
than you are to say something behind a
keyboard and just one more step further
with what they have taught me is that if
we're not careful with this whole
transhumanist transition that we're
going through that we basically make
ourselves
able to be manipulated and influenced at
unprecedented rates
because once you have a neural
prosthetic in you you can be mind
controlled and you gotta be gotta be
really really really wise and aware and
collaborative and loving compassionate
and have a deep connection with source
especially like if you look at all of
the is the with what they're selling is
they're selling you you not needing to
have the bandwidth limitation of
pressing fingers on computer keyboards
but rather literally your thought can
lead to creation and so when my
creativity is not limited to that
bandwidth but instead I can just be
thinking and creating and arranging and
building but I can have so much more
potential so that's kind of their the
the pitch for it but we do need to be
very very spiritually wise and graduated
from kindergarten prior to unleashing
such technologies that have
speeds of democratization that are
unprecedented and also
[Music]
it's a complicated transition to the
exponential technologies and sometimes
it feels like some of us including
including me and even younger people
than me that are 15 and 5 that
do they even know the capacity of their
biology for closing their eyes and
loving what's there because when you're
born with it and you've never had time
without it which we all had time without
it because we were born in the times
prior to the devices so that's one of
the big question marks and a lot of
people just say a DAB but there's like I
just adapt like if you know the child is
doing it a certain way just adapt to how
they're doing it and whatnot which
there's some truth to that but there's
also this nuance of like
yeah yeah well yeah yeah you just said
the people are forgetting communication
channels it's just like there's just one
probably there's just there's just one
other thought on that subject which is
that
I love children and I want to see
children find their gifts fast and
children finding their gifts fast has a
lot to do with them having their basic
needs met and being exposed to a bunch
of different things for them to figure
out what they what is their gift yet so
many kids around the world are not
having their basic needs met and are not
being exposed to this wide array of
options and so some of the promises of
these expedition technologies are that
if you solve the theory of everything
then we will begin to eradicate all of
the poverty and malevolence --is that
exist and we will achieve all the
sustainable development goals and so
it's an interesting multivariate
conversation
yes please you had something you had the
mic
I had something well
Mike you inspire me so much by the
things that you say you just trigger
things for me and one thing that you
inspired me to share was that my stepdad
told all of us his kids that he knew
that there was nothing after he passes
away and there is no one he died when he
was 53 and I was 35 there is no one
we've ever known who has been so close
to us even after he's passed away than
him so most of my siblings got tattoos
in honor of him we talked about him
regularly miss him think of him he
he is present with us somehow and I just
found it so ironic that he was so
adamant that there is no God and that
there is nothing after and yet he lives
so strongly so be careful what you say
you never know because love is what
endures and one thing that he did was
every moment with every person being
this very demonstrative love and it
didn't leave the hundreds of people that
he touched
we're still saying people's names and
talking about people that were dead
thousand years ago it's kind of
interesting how the presence of that
sticks around - yeah like the ancestry
that you were talking about the lineage
how you see your mom is absolutely gonna
be with you like me yeah especially
after so much time passed together yeah
my mom has said the same thing yeah
you're she's in you in yes yes anything
that feels like that sometimes being in
different cities when you're literally
on other sides of the planet or that you
can tap into the through that collective
web you can tap in to what feels like
the presence of my mother although we
are thousands of miles away from each
other or what can be like you can tap
into someone that has existed even a
long time ago and tap into their
teachings and what you'd be like feels
like I'm almost channeling what they
they're who they are in their essence
for a little bit so
timeless
I recall feeling that certainty one
moment looking into my children's eyes
have two sons one daughter six 15 and 19
and and with the time shared and the
lessons shared and the wisdom shared I
was confident that I would live beyond
me that I would still be living though I
was not present in this body like I am
but my wisdom and my lessons and my
experiences I am a story yes and my
story would continue to be shared and my
personality was still shine through my
daughter you know through the biology
through the divine biology and the
creation of all in the way it works that
that though I am NOT here I am still
here
through her through him and through him
and that I am not dead but alive
interesting story initials that you pass
to your children the mutational etc are
evident in their moment to moment life
as well as and what they continue
passing down even long after we're gone
so it's as though then out of all those
hundred billion people that built this
incredible civilization that we now live
in they are all present through all of
the lineage of transmitting all of the
collective knowledge over time of all
that we have now
how are we feeling
[Music]
yeah likewise
how do we feel about the discussion do
we feel like there are I mean other
thoughts that we want to share
we start to think about technology kids
and everything else extension of this
conversation is like now is technology
get you can modify a you know like what
you wanted in kids like more math
knowledge or something to build in
genetic engineering this one is I think
totally wrong you are changing creation
of identity of your child what is you
know only supposed to be your child and
you modifying this through generic you
know two additions something to what
question would be if they were to be
born with a very serious disease or
ailment and you chose to not engineer
that away then was there lesson to come
in and experience that ailment and then
we engineered it away so they weren't
able to have that lesson talking about
engineering like most more Turkey it's
like basically engineering you know kid
who will be already not as much as your
kid that will be something what is
artificial changed built basically so
this conversation that we're having
right now in 100 years will they be
having this conversation or will it just
be such a normal I know I don't know
sometimes it feels like if we just
project the trajectory out a couple
decades or a century and we just say
that they'll be looking back and saying
that yeah why were you exactly not a
mall it's going to be very normalized
that's the trajectory and seem with
another really obvious one is like clean
meat people are slaughtering billions of
animals on the planet and in the future
it would be like I can't believe your
doing that here's clean meat groaning
bioreactors thumbs up and another one is
that you right now it's I don't know I'm
not really me another another one is
children looking back and saying that I
can't believe that you were burning
fossil fuels at such unprecedented rates
and and putting the planet into such
ecological potentiality Astra fee and so
to again to transition to you to
transition to fusion at faster rates
again this is one of the most paramount
things as again is for the sustainable
development goals for the theory of
everything in physics to figure out how
to do what happens in the Sun on our
planet in as safe and as
energy-efficient circumstances as
possible can unleash a whole new era of
abundance and energy where everyone can
have any amount of energy anytime they
want and it's all clean yeah but that
can also draw us back to yeah there's
there's ways to handle it it would say
yeah that is you know development of
energy resources but it's basic you know
progress in our lives and by limitation
of this and you know a limitation of
fossil fuel that can be limitation so
back to
one you know I guess one thing that I
think of is it's all on it how long have
you been in San Francisco then did you
since I was 19 so 7 years 7 years yeah
and you know hearing you talk about
certain things I mean these are things
I've kind of thought about too but you
know in flyover country here I don't
think you you know you are with the
people you're interviewing there too I
imagine I haven't looked at all your
interviews but this is a conversation
like even I've never thought of you know
this other thing that you talked about
about basically implanting some kind of
a I mean I have not not thought or read
or talked about that in flyover country
here at all and when you brought that up
I was like oh my god yeah that is I can
see that is gonna hat that's gonna
happen is it's yeah why not just have
something implanted in you so you don't
have to type you just think it and it
goes but yet eventually that's can be a
control mechanism so you know living
living out there seven years is all and
and and I mean you've interviewed just
it looks like hundreds of people right
and and then seeing what's happening and
in the progression of things the way
it's moving yeah it has to feel so I
think you know this is one of the things
I've said if if Donald Trump gets in to
office again I'm probably I'm aiming
towards going somewhere more liberal and
within the United States or out because
yeah I just I'm sick of you know I'm
sick of fighting him and then I gotta
fight a governor here too and I just
don't know how much of it I can put up
with it I'm
I'm violent I'm doing as much as I can
to volunteer but the prison they teach
some yoga and stuff but you know I just
really don't know I wanna pee I want to
be where people are and so to in some
degree I would guess that you you know
you're in a bubble out there and in
Oregon is kind of the same as people
Oregon and stuff it is actually one of
the crazy things about that bubble is
not only what you were saying about how
we can do things like be at the edge of
society's knowledge about how to Jam
chips into people's brains and other
people around the world are not talking
about that even in the middle of the
United States not talking about that let
alone people that don't have basic needs
around the world but then there's how
ironically people in Silicon Valley have
some of the least amount of
conversations about source about God
about the divine about creation some of
the least only really recently what this
whole idea of being in a simulation has
there been more and more ideas about
okay let's revisit God or the divine or
creation but really there's a lack of
ethicists there's a lack of moral
scientists there's a lack of
philosophers there's a lack of of people
that study theology there's a lack of
all of those disciplines within every
single one of the major tech companies
in Silicon Valley also the major tech
companies in China there's just a
serious lack you have people that are
making AI that are mostly white guys in
Silicon Valley or white or Chinese men
in China and there's a lack of again
lack of female perspective a lack of
just philosophies from around the world
and I think it's becoming more and more
clear that if you
do not have ethicists philosophers moral
scientists spiritual leaders that are
within those tech companies around the
world that's gonna be the recipe for
disaster and just want ya one
interesting thing I add to this as you
know when I studied yoga you've heard of
the book but the biography of a yogi of
Yogananda he he came into the United
States and first he went to I think it
was New York to the East East Coast and
he was he was he was like these people
there's there's nothing I can do with
these people so he flew to California
from what I understand I and I I may be
kind of fuzzy on some things but he
decided that's where I'm gonna go and
try to establish a yoga foundation and
there he found ok I can hit these people
I can deal with and he still had a
problem there and that the people he had
some people that he was training and
they ended up having sexual relations
with people's wives and things and it
turned into a big term tumultuous thing
and he went back to Indian he was
intending to not come back he's like
that is some messed up stuff over there
but he did come back but I think it's
it's fascinating that you're saying you
know there's none of this happening
there and that is the bed of where a lot
of this yoga existed and and he
developed and needs to be more in there
and it came across that way where we
were thinking the East Coast was in such
bad shape and was I or he was or he was
saying so there was a recent movie in
the in the 12 where they had the 12
different indigenous tribes from around
the world come together at the United
Nations to
helped put up a calling to spirit to
guide the trajectory of our planet in a
more benevolent direction and one of the
tribes of in a cap going from the
airport into Manhattan and they said in
their language and it got translated
obviously in the subtitles but they said
there are no trees when they're driving
into Manhattan and
yeah when you just have a massive
concrete jungle again you can't you
can't it's hot it's so hard it's not
like you there's you don't go to the
cave because again you need to bring
your connection to divine your gifts
forward if you're in the cave you're not
bringing the gifts to other people but
you go into Manhattan or any actually
really metropolis nowadays because
they're like I believe it's over fifty
percent of people in civilization live
in Metropolis now and they're all
concrete jungles even though some have a
higher density of parks like cool but
there's still concrete jungles and you
can't successfully tune yourself to the
divine like a tuning fork when you're
constantly bombarded by EMF cars humans
economy that's roaring around you one of
the things you guys have in Sioux Falls
is fantastic is you have a lot more
spread space it's just it is and it and
you have your own like grass that you
can lay in in the sunlight you know you
can actually go out and open your deck
door and go look at the full moon can't
when you're crammed into the little
boxes that are all on top of each other
next to other boxes which is in that
yesterday if you want to tune yourself
like a tuning fork to the divine we must
redesign our living situations around
the planet away from concrete jungles
and towards our ecology which mixes the
other architecture in ecology and yeah
yeah that's that's that's that's a big
one
only thing I haven't mentioned from my
page and I'll speak to but I want to say
thank you for the direction a call to
discipline to dip into my body during
the time they're enduring divine times
in the morning the evening at night call
to discipline more so than just to you
know a devotion to a word or any other
thing besides you know that in which is
inside of me you know and when I also
recall the the gift of leaving my body
and going far far far away and then
coming back but I appreciate truly the
the reminder the encouragement the call
to discipline to dip into my body and go
into that space and to love it and so
just wanted to thank you for that for
that for that call to discipline thank
you yeah
what I hadn't mentioned was if we don't
repair then we repeat yeah
and I do subscribe to this way of life
that says it is a it is a classroom and
that that everything is a lesson and
that that I am here because of lessons I
need to learn and haven't learned yet
and and it actually allows for me to
embrace the hard times
yes that in which the the deepest
lessons are learned of the most rich
lessons are learned you know people then
you know business sense they'll say you
know embrace failures and all these
different things that coach you and call
you to embrace the fall because of what
you learn while you're down and I've
seen so many downs in my life growing up
in the inner city drug violence and
gangs everywhere a lot of criminality my
own you know experiences with
incarceration and reentry and I have
learned the most through those setbacks
I've become better and stronger because
of the process of the comeback you know
and as I continue to embrace again
another mantra of mine personally that
life is not wins and losses but life is
wins and lessons and that I am here to
learn as many lessons as I can and every
one that I'm learning I it was meant for
me to experience and so I look forward
to the time in which I leave and don't
have to come back and that I just exist
not here but there and I'm able to just
be in the all knowing and the all
present and in the everlasting flow of
all of it and just to watch
myself in other versions and forums
learning lessons along the way and so I
celebrate this time as Terry Liggins and
then 34 and start in the starting a
business and just learning so many
things along the way the value of
mentorship new friendships and just the
lessons you learn along the way but I
subscribe to life being a classroom and
that I'm here to learn how our worldview
profoundly changes when we see
everything as lessons everything
everything even when we do something as
simple as we're like moving a little too
fast instead of kind of flowing a little
more spiritually as we're moving and we
like stub our tour we hit our head or we
do something like that that's literally
a lesson like slow down mmm this is it's
everywhere all those lessons are
everywhere it's a school and even the
smallest tiny synchronicities are our
lessons everything someone's calling you
out even though sometimes you can feel
like someone's like projecting their
[ __ ] on you yeah even if you can also
tap in at the same time of like whoa
what are they actually trying to like
teach me right now what is this teaching
me yeah yeah yeah that that activation
and body is a call to learning you know
we're experiencing it together and we're
both going and growing through something
it's not just happening to them or me
it's happening to us love it and
whatever the experience is even though
it may seem as if I am on the the short
the short side of it you know anger if
something angers me what is that about
you know something irritates me
irritation agitation frustration that's
a call to learning all those things are
a call to learning it is grateful to
experience bliss and joy and laughter
but when you find yourself irritated
agitated aggravated it is a call to
learning for yourself and when you get
consumed by wanting to change that in
which was already called to teach you my
friend one of the one of the preachers I
followed the guy what's his name verdict
he said he said sometimes you're it's
your opposition that shows up but it's
truly an opportunity ah your opposition
knocks on the door and you think that
why the hell are you here you know what
the hell's going on not puny for you
both it is so interesting yeah
opportunity for both them and for
yourself to both learn yeah yeah all of
it from all of it so so it caused me to
embrace those pains those dark places
that I've been that I know the roots
have to reach down to hell sometimes for
the leaves and fruit to reach to the
heavens amen praise God I'm grateful I'm
so grateful they this sect this
discussion and Q&A portion has been so
damn good yeah yeah so fire some of the
best stuff comes from the interplay of
the spirits afterward
yeah it's good any any thoughts
take
so when we talk about concern of what
will happen to youth and and what will
come of the future with the developments
of technology that supersede our wisdom
it is it is possible that in the process
of destroying ourselves we will come to
our senses and already the mental health
profession points to mindfulness and and
it's possible that as wisdom infiltrates
as source has its own energy and power
perhaps
mindfulness apps you know there there
may be things that then counter that
destruction as we realize that we can
not survive as only thinking beings but
we need that spiritual component in life
yes I think perhaps we put maybe too
much stock at times in into thinking
mm-hmm rather feeling spirituality for
sure does the divine source think maybe
not as significant as acknowledging that
the divine is knowledge and wisdom mmm
in and of itself mm-hmm and our thinking
doesn't necessarily get us there either
beautiful but it is the receiving of
truth that taps into the eternal truth
and
yeah when we look again at the the stack
of cards that is our life and Terry
talks about being born again tonight I'm
reminded that we are born again now
moment to moment and now yeah and now
every moment and as we receive what
truth is right now rather than thinking
thinking we receive what we are learning
from each other and through these
experiences and through whatever pain or
discomfort is teaching us we are more
one with the need to not even think at
all yeah but we are part of the knowing
and the truth itself with every moment
every moment every moment and regardless
of what technology does we will find
ourselves needing to focus on the fact
that we are human beings and and who we
it's it's about what it's about the
being you know and if the source is the
I am what we are at each moment that
taps in more than the I'm thinking I'm
doing I'm striving
yeah
it's good thank you Wow giving us good
good discussion
so moment to moment we are born again
every moment yes any and there's the
more that we seek towards truth the more
we see always lessons the more moments
moment we keep leveling up more and more
towards that divine communion returning
to it returning to it
remembering the source from whence we
came wherein as all fullness of truth
with laughter with laughter along yes
yes
it's so important to export this feeling
to the rest of our evening and tomorrow
and the next day and our friends and our
families and our communities and the
world should continue that as you build
up more and more of those
moment-to-moment experiences to take and
to be able to share the gift it's
critical
then it's not an it's not an overnight
flick of the light switch in that
direction either it's definitely a very
slow process of being better than we
were yesterday and incrementally making
those improvements
more than and and just more
by calling for more seeking out more
yeah yeah I think about the gift they're
in and showing up there was a call there
was an answer yeah
now there's a fullness yes because of
the unity yes you know I take force the
unity into the evening and to tomorrow
to our families and our friends the
togetherness the one that's the
lightness yeah yeah
the inner rhythm
they Lyanna rhythm this was such
blessing yes yeah there's even closer
yeah
and so I had this thought I work with
the Native Americans up at the but the
prison and and you know I would just
like to put out something I shared to a
band that was here in town recently that
was thanking veterans I would like to I
just want to thank the Native people and
people that were enslaved in this
country and and that died defending
their homes that defending their land
and their way of life and I just want to
acknowledge those people before us
[Music]
there is no greater honor than time
and no greater experience than to
excape it to leave time
I'm grateful and thankful to spend time
with you friends
[Music]
use it wisely
share it
place it more onerous do those who are
living out love looking to strengthen
love
to inspire love
Mike I appreciate so much you honoring
those that have gone before us and their
way and then our sacrifice honors do
on her time
Wow
this was so special
so grateful for it
so very
Wow
okay yeah it's good thank you for its
forever it goes on forever - it never
ends
to the eternal flow
so damn special
I won't I would like to I'd like to
thank everyone that has been tuning in
for the discussion yeah oh yeah we've
been recording and so it will yeah we
will put it yeah we will put it it will
be it will be the whole thing will be up
yeah yeah so thank you everyone for
tuning in and checking out the
discussion and Q&A portion of the
ultimate nature of reality we greatly
appreciate you we'd love to hear your
thoughts and the comments below on the
topics that we discussed we'd love to
hear from you have more conversations
with your self with your friends your
family coworkers people online about
source about bringing your gifts forward
about understanding the source code
and check out the links in the bio to
everyone support the artists
entrepreneurs the organization's the
spiritual leaders that you believe in
around the world support them help them
grow you can find all of our links below
to our paypal cryptocurrency patreon
design cool merch and get paid all those
links are below and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we all love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon